[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jacqueline gourault bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos ministres la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales les sujets sont nombreux
en bien sûr avec vous on va en parler à
mes côtés pour cette interview romain
gaspard bonjour en 20 jours journaliste
à la gazette des communes avant de
parler des sujets qui touchent de près
les collectivités on va bien sûr parler
de cette actualité dramatique cet
assassinat de samuel pâtit ce professeur
d'histoire géographie et le gouvernement
qui annonce des mesures depuis hier des
plans pour lutter notamment contre les
associations proches des milieux
radicaliser gérald darmanin qui
demandent la dissolution du ccf qui
annonce hier soir avoir demandé la
fermeture de la mosquée de pantin le
gouvernement réagit mais il aura fallu
sept assassinats pour que le
gouvernement réagisse de manière aussi
ferme d'abord permettez moi de dire que
je pense beaucoup à tous ceux qui
étaient proches de ce professeur samuel
patil je pense bien sûr c'était d'abord
un fils c'est un père il a beaucoup
d'amis il a beaucoup de collègues
je pense aussi aux jeunes pour qu'ils
les maîtres sont très importants dans
leur formation est donc évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui est très blessants
pour la société et cet acte barbare je
dirais frappe notre société frappe notre
république est évidemment l'hommage qui
lui sera rendu demain dans la cour de la
sorbonne sera un moment extrêmement fort
je me permets de vous dire que bien sûr
la lie lutte contre l'islamisme radical
va trouver des réponses fortes
après ce meurtre barbare mais bien sûr
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis des mois et vous le
savez bien et le président de la
république s'est exprimé il y à peu aux
mureaux et puisque françoise gatel était
juste avant moi à votre à votre micro je
voudrais aussi la remercier vous vous
rappelez du texte qu'elle avait fait sur
l'école avec donc je pense que healy a
depuis longtemps une prise de conscience
mais cet événement dramatique monstrueux
va accélérer bien sûr les prises des
décisions c'est évident accélérer les
prises de décisions ça veut dire que la
loi sur le séparatisme pourrait être
avancée je ne sais pas je n'ai pas de
précisions sur le comment dire le
calendrier on sait que c'était prévu
début décembre
peut-être je n'ai pas d'information
précise mais c'était à ce sujet mais ça
n'est pas exclu mais en tout cas comme
vous le savez un certain nombre de
choses ont été annoncées
y compris par le président de la
république et le premier ministre est
bien sûr gérald darmanin et parmi ces
choses et à la sécurisation des écoles
on en parle avec ronan tout à fait il ya
une des propositions qui a été amené par
gérald darmanin fait la sécurisation des
écoles
comment ça va se passer et puis on avait
on a appris il ya trois semaines la
suppression de l'observatoire national
de la sécurité et de l'accessibilité des
établissements
est ce que finalement ça pourrait être
maintenue est ce que ça joue un rôle
dans cette sécurisation
ce qui compte c'est l'efficacité j'ai
été maire pendant 25 ans je sais ce que
c'est que ces cures idée des écoles j'ai
même
vécu aussi lorsque j'étais maire un
événement dramatique avec des enfants
qui étaient dans l'école et il était
arrivé un grand malheur à une à leur
mère il a fallu sécuriser dans la
journée enfin bon il est évident que
c'est un sujet très important et qu'il
faut au regard des risques qui pèsent
sur les enseignants prendre des
décisions complémentaires pour sécuriser
les écoles et gérald un malin va le
faire mais je lui fais ta c'est l'état
qui va gérer ou c'est les maires dans
les écoles via le centre pour les
collèges où les régions pourraient sur
les espaces et comment concrètement mais
écoutez comme toute chose nous en
parlerons sûrement la suite comme tout
saute on ne peut pas imaginer que healy
à l'état d'un côté les collectivités
territoriales de l'autre ceux qui
cherchent à défendre cela ou même a
opposé l'état et les collectivités
territoriales se trompe car dans des cas
comme celui que nous venons de vivre
naturellement la réponse des sera aussi
entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
chacun jouera son rôle il y à des
polices municipales
il y à la police nationale il faudra
mettre un système d'efficacité pour
protéger les enseignants qui sont en
danger
puisqu'on parle de ses élus c'est vrai
qu'on entende depuis quelques jours
encore plus un c est lui qui nous disent
que souvent ils sont seuls dans cette
lutte contre le communautarisme que
souvent ils veulent prendre des mesures
mais que le droit ne leur permet pas de
le faire est ce que il va y avoir plus
de moyens et plus de protection pour les
élus dans la lutte contre le
communautarisme
vous savez bien qu'un certain nombre de
choses ont été prises ont rappelé la loi
avia et ça a été mis sur le tas lui la
lutte dans la lutte contre la haine en
ligne mais cratère dolomieu par le
conseil constitutionnel solu mans donc
le gouvernement et sa majorité ont pris
un certain nombre de décisions
il y a des choses qu'il faut revoir
remettre sur le chantier à cause de
décisions comme celle du conseil
constitutionnel
elle s'est à plusieurs niveaux et vous
savez que le projet de loi qui existait
avant ce dramatique assassinat va
toucher plusieurs secteurs à la fois
l'école à la fois les associations à la
fois les comment dire les
l'accompagnement de l'état pour faire en
sorte que des mesures soient prises pour
favoriser la mixité sociale
l'enseignement comme ça a déjà été fait
par monsieur blanc caire en dédoublant
les classes en rep et c'est pour qu'on
s'occupe des enfants et que surtout ils
soient scolarisés dès 3 ans sauf pour
raisons médicales
parce que on sait très bien qu'on ne
peut pas laisser des enfants de
certaines familles dans les mains des
extrémistes
les maires doivent-ils avoir accès au
fichier reste pour radicalisation comme
beaucoup le demande je crois que
l'efficacité et j'ai toujours défendu
cette position du fichier s et de la
radicalisation doit son efficacité aussi
quand il y a une certaine comment dire
certaines indiscrétions incertain
[Musique]
l'efficacité est liée au fait que
l'information ne circule pas partout et
donc je ne suis pas favorable à ce que
les mères est un accès au fichier s mais
je suis favorable à ce quand il y a un
problème précis que les maires en soient
informés dernière question sur ce sujet
rendant il ya une des critiques qui
avaient été faits à la loi contre les
séparatistes
enfin dans un grand discours de manuel
macron c'est le manque de mesures ce
contre la ghettoïsation
est ce que vous allez renforcer ce plan
là et comment et comment la
ghettoïsation vous voulez dire
le fait qu'il y ait des grands ensembles
que les populations soient voilà la
mixité sociale est quelque chose qui a
été toujours une recherche importante de
ce gouvernement est d'ailleurs des
précédents
grand projet de l'anru avait bien sûr
cette vocation
l' agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine qui était bien sûr de
reconstruire l'habitat de façon plus
moderne et plus comment dire ouverte
mais il y avait aussi l'aspect
accompagnement social et luttent contre
lac de théoriciens et dans beaucoup
d'endroits aussi les maires font des
projets de construction qui allie à la
fois l'accès à la propriété et le
logement social
et c'est quelque chose qui est fait donc
beaucoup beaucoup de villes de france
on va parler des congrès dé lui le
combat des régions de france qui avait
lieu hier toute la journée à paris alors
les présidents de région ils disent
qu'ils sont satisfaits du dialogue qui
se noue avec jean castex ils sont
satisfaits de l'accord sur le plan de
relance qui a été signée ils disent sur
la forme c'est bien le dialogue est là
mais maintenant on attend les actes
c'est pour quand les actes chaque mot à
bien le plan de relance vous savez que
c'est un plan exceptionnel qui va lutter
contre les conséquences de la crise de
l'aco vide sur le plan économique et
social
alors peut-être les actes il faut quand
même mesuré que il y a un budget à voter
que ceux ci a été débuté à l'assemblée
nationale et que
les comment dire le plan doit être votée
mais comme vous le savez beaucoup de
choses ont été faites déjà
j'écoutais à l'instant encore une fois
françoise gatel qui parlait qui
racontait que sur le terrain les élus
connaissait les chefs d'entreprises etc
mais vous savez que l'état a soutenu
beaucoup les entreprises dans cette
crise du coc vider des millions ont déjà
été dépensés pour garantir les prêts
pour exonérer les charges pour soutenir
les salariés avec le chômage partiel
beaucoup de choses ça ce sont des actes
précis et quand on parle du plan de
relance on est déjà dans le troisième
étage de la fusée
si je puis dire il faut voir les sommes
considérables qui ont été déjà déboursé
par l'état pour accompagner ces
entreprises
d'ailleurs je dois dire que le monde des
entreprises en particulier les mondes
des petites entreprises des moyennes et
petites entreprises et les commerçants
le savent bien
car sur le terrain par exemple souvent
on m'a remerciée de ce qui a été fait
par le gouvernement
et là encore vous voyez l'information
vient du terrain et aussi l'état agit au
niveau et les français s'habituent à des
classements l'état agisse ya des
questions qui se posent de jacqueline
gourault sur la manière dont va être
piloté ce plan de relance sur la manière
dont vont être fléché les crédits hier
gérard larcher il a dit ciapa de
déconcentration du plan de relance je
fais le malheureux paris que dans un an
à peine 50 % des crédits seront
consommés comment vous allez faire pour
pilot données donnent toujours l ens
oiseaux de mauvaise augure si je peux
dire mais dans ces périodes on a besoin
de se serrer les coudes et le premier
ministre a expliqué si vous avez écouté
hier son discours comment les choses
allaient être faites il ya toute une
partie des comment dire des financements
qui vont être territorialisées non
seulement ils vont être territorialisées
mais il y aura au niveau régional une co
présidence du préfet de région est
du président de région pour orienter les
comment dire les financements vers les
projets qui sont qui sont prêts et bien
évidemment il y aura aussi des
financements qui seront mis dans les
mains des préfets de région et des
préfets des départements
je vais prendre un exemple précis pour
que ça soit concret puisqu'il faut
parler du concret il va y avoir un
milliard qui va être destiné aux
collectivités territoriales dans le
domaine de des économies d'énergie et
donc de la transition écologique et il
se milliards va être destiné aussi bien
aux régions aux départements et aux
communes
c'est au fond une des cils dotation de
soutien à l'investissement local qui
sera simplement enfin très simplement
dans les mains des préfets et en direct
diffusée sur les territoires donc le
plan de relance va être territorialisée
et les élus le savent bien qu'ils sont
en train de se préparer et de faire
remonter aux préfets leur projet l'une
des inquiétudes c'est pour les petites
collectivités qui craignent les appels à
projets et un grand nombre d'appels à
projets sur le plan de relance est ce
que enfin comment vous pouvez les
rassurer d'abord il y aura le moins
possible d'appels à projets etc
la demande du président de la république
et du premier ministre
le
le ministère de l'écologie a fait un
appel à projets pour les bâtiments
d'état puisqu'il y a aussi une enveloppe
pour les magic man d'état mais comme je
viens de vous l'expliquer à l'instant
par cet exemple concret c'est pas un
appel à projets sait on a un dossier on
le présente au préfet de région et ce
sera financé non mais il ya une
inquiétude des petites collectivités qui
est qu'on parle beaucoup des régions et
moins des petites collectivités
peut être que là vous pouvez les
rassurer ah je peux concernera tout le
monde pas que les réjouit alors d'abord
il faut bien mesurer que il y accumule
cette année de beaucoup de moyens
quels sont ses moyens il ya d'abord le
budget traditionnel si je puis dire dans
lequel les dotations pour les
collectivités territoriales
en tout cas la dotation globale de
fonctionnement est maintenu à son niveau
la dotation la detr c'est à dire la
dotation d'équipement des territoires
ruraux est maintenu à un très haut
niveau également la dessine également st
c'est pour l'habitude ensuite il ya un
milliard de dhs et s'il supplémentaires
qui a été décidée il ya déjà un mois et
il ya le milliard concernant la
transition écologique
ça fait beaucoup d'argent qui vont être
destinés au territoire et au plus près
et à toutes les collectivités aient
compris les petites communes madame la
ministre puisqu'on parle de des finances
on a des élus inquiets inquiets de
l'impact de la crise financière sur leur
collectivité et agacé du coût de
certaines mesures on va écouter le
président du département de la loire
georges ziegler il est au micro de nos
partenaires de tl7
vos plein de dépenses qui augmentent
nous avons plein de recettes qui
diminuent
il ya un moment il faut tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé et dire attention on
ne peut pas tout faire alors bien sûr on
me demande effectivement on nous demande
avec hervé on a regardé de donner des
primes de donner des soutiens de données
mais le soutien on l'a fait au fil des
années constamment pour les entreprises
et les particuliers du département chez
moi on dit que celui qui commande y paye
qu'est ce que voulait répondre d'abord
le président giguère a raison il y a un
problème de financement des départements
ce n'est pas nouveau on le sait c'est à
dire que quand il ya une crise les
ressources des départements ont tendance
à baisser notamment les fameux dmt haut
c'est à dire les frais de notaire comme
on dit et puis les dépenses sociales
puisque la compétence essentielle des
départements c'est l'accompagnement
social
donc effectivement vous avez un effet
ciseau comme on dit les courbes se
croisent
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'état est
là toujours présent parce que c'est au
fond la conviction profonde des français
que l'état est là pour assurer l'égalité
des français et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le plfr 3 qui à donjons et
été voté le prendre le train
nous avons fait des avances aux
départements sur les dm théo pour les
départements qui avaient des difficultés
il faut savoir c'est un peu technique
mais que seuls 40 départements sur 80
nous ont demandé ces avances parce que
finalement dans certains départements ça
a été les recettes on a fini par
augmenter quand même un amendement au
budget qui énerve et départements vendée
dominique bussereau dénonce un
amendement scélérate celui sur la prise
de
de hausse de tva pourquoi cet amendement
est est-ce que c'est pas le milliard qui
va manquer pour financer les hausses de
rsa et il va y avoir d'autres moyens qui
vont être données aux départements et
comme vous le savez nous sommes en
discussion avec les départements
nous avons déjà annoncé un certain
nombre de choses par exemple
pour être concret il ya un fonds de
péréquation entre les départements
c'est-à-dire horizontale certains
départements les plus riches donnent de
l'argent aux plus pauvres et s'éteint un
système
je dirais qu'il a été inventé par le les
départements et qui montre je dirais la
bonne entente entre départements et la
solidarité entre département et ce fonds
il est fixé il doit atteindre 1 milliard
6 évidemment étant donné les difficultés
financières actuellement c'est difficile
bien sûr il manque de l'argent l'état
donc va compenser la différence entre ce
qu'ils ont comme moyen et le milliard si
c'est à dire que l'état va intervenir
pour la première fois dans un fonds
glee est entièrement horizontale sur les
collectivités territoriales
quant à l'amendement dont vous parlez
j'y reviens c'est simplement qu'il y à
un phénomène de ressaut entre une année
où la baisse de la tva a beaucoup baissé
et l'autre où elle a beaucoup augmenté
et donc nous allons bien sûr comme prévu
laissé au département et je ne soit dit
en passant
mais il n'ya pas laisser ce milieu au
département non et c'est pas fini
laissez moi on va laisser aux
départements la hausse
je dirais traditionnel de tva c'est à
dire à peu près 3% et leurs sauts bien
évidemment vous le reprenez on va leur
prendre et je dis pas c'est normal c'est
un ruisseau on va pas comment dire dans
ces jeunes mamans pour finir il ya donné
gayraud 10 milliards on en a besoin
d'aimer giulano milliards la crise ils
ont la hausse de 2,9 dans les années
nous coûte rien faut que dominique
bussereau disent aussi ce qu'on propose
à côté c'est à dire il ya ceux que je
viens d exprimer
et puis il ya un fonds de stabilisation
ou un fonds d'urgence on l'appelle
combat comme on veut qui va être aussi
versé au département et dont nous allons
discuter ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que cette histoire de ressaut pour
la tva et ça il n'y a pas que les
départements qui sont concernés les
intercoms les intercoms sont aussi
concernés il nous reste peu de temps
jacqueline gourault ce matin a lieu la
conférence des territoires alors il faut
plus l'appeler conférence des
territoires conférence état collectivité
mais bon c'est le gouvernement qui
réunit les associations d'élus
finalement elle avait capoté cette
conférence de territoire elle est remise
au goût du jour est ce que finalement
c'est dans les vieux pots qu'on fait les
meilleures confitures cette rencontre
entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales est importante elle sera
un niveau un peu plus resserrée nous
avons organisé cette rencontre avec les
associations d'élus tels la série tel
quel et la cnt pardon telle qu'elle
existait en sensualité
très importante avec beaucoup de monde
et et ça n'était pas toujours très
constructif donc là nous avons réduit le
nombre est bien sûr nous allons parler
ce matin de plusieurs thèmes bien sûr
nous allons parler de l'actualité
évidemment et de ce qui se passe dans ce
pays deuxièmement nous allons parler de
la relance bien évidemment et nous
allons parler aussi de la crise de l'aco
vide et nous allons parler aussi de la
loi 3d il y aura des annonces bah
écoutez il y aura un certain nombre de
dossiers qui seront précisées bien
évidemment notamment peut-être la loi
trader on a enfin parlé oui il y avait
la loi 3d ma pensée la loi cadre des dsk
rejouera va arriver au parlement et il y
aura combien de d à ce moment là quand
elle va arriver au parlement cette loi
alors je sais qu'on peut faire de
l'humour mais ce qui est important c'est
de répondre aux collectivités
territoriales et à leurs attentes
vous savez vous savez permettez moi
d'expliquer
d'abord je rappelle que nous avons votée
en décembre de l'année dernière une loi
qui s'appelait engagement et proximité
qui a été une première étape
ensuite nous avons commencé des
concertations pour la loi 3d et je
rappelle pour les téléspectateurs
la loi décentralisation différenciation
des concentrations comme vous le savez
il ya eu la crise du co by death a
quelque peu ralenti les concertations
alors on ne peut pas à la fois nous dire
qu on a besoin de concertation avec les
élus et que quand on n'a pas pu la
terminer
on nous reproche de ne pas aller assez
vite et comme vous il ne vous a pas
échappé
bien évidemment le calendrier
parlementaire est assez chargé ceci dit
ça veut dire qu'elles ne sont pas si la
première partie de la loi c'est-à-dire
le projet de loi organique arrive en
lecture ici au sénat puisque c'est
d'abord le sénat qui examine le 2
novembre
c'est la première étape de
ce projet de loi 3d c'est à dire le côté
différenciation ensuite bien évidemment
un projet de loi va être finalisée dans
sa rédaction pour la fin de l'année et
le texte devrait passer je n'ai pas de
date précise comme personne d'ailleurs
n'a de date précise pour ses textes au
premier semestre 2001 21
ça c'est maintenant lui avant l'été que
je le dis et que je le répète et on peut
dire aussi vous pourriez me poser la
question est-ce que c'est avant ou après
les élections
eh bien je vais vous dire aussi que vous
avez vu qui a certain nombre de
départements qui ont demandé à ce qu'on
reporte les élections pour cause bien
sûr de covin mais alors bien que vous
m'en parler puisque les régions les
présidents de région hier les présidents
de région hier à l'unanimité ont dit non
non nous on veut pas remporté les
élections veut les garder en mars
oui est-ce que du coup vous pouvez
reporter les régionales contre l'avis
des présidents de région mais écoutez
c'est la crise sanitaire qui le dira il
n'y a pas d'autres sujets on a eu
l'exemple
je dirais des difficultés lors des
municipales
on sait comment ça s'est passé on va en
tirer les leçons
et naturellement la décision sera prise
en fonction de la crise sanitaire et ça
sera malheureusement le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup mais l'accession au
ministre d'avoir été avec nous merci
roman on regarde la lune de la gazette
des communes roman cette semaine que
prédateur et éleveurs les mains au coeur
de la mêlée c'est à la une de votre
journal merci
[Musique]